c'est intéressant qui s'y colle comme
sans google phone ouais t'as pas de
surcouche avec un milliard
d'applications inutiles et c'est assez
épuré j'ai posé la question alors
d'aboutir j'ai eu une sous couche
il me regarde j'épluche robert mais je
disais qu'on ne s'est pas excusé moi
[Musique]
tu arrêtes avec l'histoire d'une joie
tout ça moi tout ça ah oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retrouvent aujourd'hui pour la
présentation du pixel 3 pixels 3xl par
google alors ya eu des produits qui ont
été présentées pour les états unis
l'angleterre et l'australie
un petit peu frustré pour l'instant on
va attendre les produits vont
probablement arriver d'ici quelques
temps on va se concentrer nous sur le
pixel 3 et le pixel 3xl c'est vrai qu'en
france les smartphones de google
n'étaient toujours pas présents qu'on
pouvait les avoir en apport notamment
avec le pixel 2 qu'elle est vraiment
fait ses preuves en termes de photos là
je crois qu'avec le pixel trois ils vont
vraiment confirmé confirmé à pelé c'est
parce que le l'idée de google là dessus
c'est vraiment d'avoir un côté software
complètement ouf estime alors on est
avec raphaël qui est directeur marketing
de google france savannah est bien un
excellent web ont la grosse grosse
grosse présentation notamment du pixel 3
qui arrive en france
alors est ce que tu peux venir un peu
quelle est la volonté de google sur
l'arrivée de ce pixel 3 qu'est-ce qu'on
va véhiculer comme on vive à leurs
besoins avec un tout nouveau smartphone
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu celle
de l'année dernière pixels
en france c'est la première fois que
google art déco smartphones enfin enfin
coup d'état quand on est très ravis de
voir le pixel trois arrivées by pixel 3
s'il fallait résumer c'est le meilleur
du hardware le meilleur l'histoire et
une couche d'intelligence artificielle
ou un pardessus qui en gros a une
faculté extraordinaire c'est que ça crée
des nouvelles fonctionnalités
ça rend possible des choses qui étaient
pas disponibles avant ouais donc
l'excellence de la caméra une batterie
intelligente qui optimise la dépense de
la batterie pour que mal leur dure toute
la journée
le fait que l'on puisse profiter de
google labs
et donc faire profiter des bénéfices de
la réalité augmentée le fait qu'on ait
par exemple des fonctionnalités de bien
être numérique pouvoir être sûr de bien
l'utiliser numérique c'est quoi le livre
numérique le bienvenu mairie c'est se
dire est-ce que je passe le bon nombre
d'heures et le bon temps sur ces des
appareils est ce que en gros gras des
outils je peux prendre le contrôle de sa
et va assurer que le jeu utilise au bon
moment et pas trop et donc déjà avoir
connaissance du temps que je passe sur
les applications et parfois et bien y
mettre des limites lorsque je pense que
voilà je vais pas dépassé trop de temps
etc
il ya des petites fonctionnalités qui il
peut aider à décrocher un rôle
totalement typiquement je me rends
compte que j'ai passé 35 minutes
aujourd'hui sur le téléphone et j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps sur youtube donc
ce que je vais vouloir faire s'est fixé
une limite son utilisation et youtube
j'ai cliqué sur youtube je vais avoir un
récapitulatif des monts utilisation par
jour ou par heure je vais pouvoir
paramétrer les différentes notifications
de youtube et je vais pouvoir dessiner
un minute koné j'ai mis le minuteur à 5
minutes pour l'exemple donc là une fois
que je retombe sur mon écran d'accueil
donc je vais sur youtube je vois que
l'application est brisé
con si j'essaie d'y accéder il va me
dire que l'application pense que
comparer un rival ce genre j avais
simplement ses spécificités techniques
en fait c'est révolu fatalement puisque
grâce à la couche sauf que
l'intelligence artificielle on autorise
les usages qui était pas disponible avec
donc on le voit à faire les
fonctionnalités de photos si je prends
un exemple avec la clope division de la
batterie à gauche software va regarder
comment est-ce qu'on utilise des biens
le téléphone et optimiser la batterie
pour pas trop la dépenser et garder
juste l'énergie pour les fonctionnalités
les plus intéressantes
je trouve ça sur toute une gamme et bien
depuis
alors google a fait le choix d'avoir
deux écrans quelle taille d'écran alors
il ya un écran de 5,5 et un deuxième
gain qui se pose est quel recul 3 donc
en pixels droite cette voie excellent
ils viennent les deux avec les mêmes
fonctionnalités
on n'a pas encore choisir pas de
compromis pas de compromis les deux
arrivent avec la double que l'on dira
caméra sur la face avant permet
justement de faire l'essai lfi
grand-angle ça c'est absolument
redoutable puisque derrière on a plus de
70 ans de son espace et donc vous verrez
que le plus besoin de salfit fixé
absolument révolue et donc plein de
bénéfice net à dire que les deux caméras
travail en même temps qu'on avait
actuellement quand même temps pour
vraiment 4 c'est pas vraiment l'une ou
l'autre c'est vraiment les deux qui
bossent en même temps tu donne une image
douves
elles sont complètes et au placard 2
c'est qu'on a un traitement
algorithmique effet derrière sur
l'imagerie de manière à assurer que
l'image soit la plus pure et la plus
parfaite quelques doses produites
présenter une tablette le
google au mob est ce que on peut espérer
pour arriver s'est produit dans l'émoi
ville où est ce que tu penses que c'est
des choses du fort attrait la génération
suivante pour ça l'objectif c'est
toujours de travailler le plus dur
possible pour amener les meilleures
innovations vous marché français aussi
ça fait quatre ans qu'on a commencé
l'aventuré de l'art aujourd'hui si je
lis chrome qu'un c'est toute la gamme
naissent ainsi que le routeur wifi et
toute la gamme home et maintenant pixels
et en plus je vive parler des pixels
buzz sens de l'histoire
xl stand aussi que cette station
d'accueil de recherche sans fil c'est le
sens de l'histoire alors on continue de
travailler dur pour amener meilleur des
technologies aux français bon écoute
c'est parfait je te remercie beaucoup
[Musique]
omnium ça vas y toi alors tu en penses
quoi de tes nouveaux pixels 3 pas génial
de mitigé ouais je suis à des assez déçu
du pétard mouillé que google a un peu
fait avec tous les youtube heures qui
ont dit qu'on connaissait tout cela dit
en fait vous savez pas tout et puis en
fait va si on savait tous donc un peu
déçu je trouve que ça manquait pas
manqué d'aller vraiment d'un petit et et
wau failli manquer quelque chose
d'accord voilà pas convaincu du tout
j'aime quand même bien pour donner à des
côtés positifs
j'aime bien le form factor du pixel
trois classiques parce qu'il tient bien
en main
bon l'écran est pas bord à bord n'est
tant pis mais il tient bien en main il
est agréable à utiliser et je trouve que
ça manque un peu aujourd'hui dans le
milieu des smartphones on a vraiment
beaucoup de smartphones qui sont quand
même très gros de plus en plus oui et ça
fait du bien d'avoir un smartphone j'ai
pu le prendre en main qui tient grecque
est agréable à ils ont bien travaillé ça
voilà un peu encoches sur leur excellent
l'encoche d'ixelles et par lé au crible
ces rappels pas non pas du tout non non
et d'un point de vue logiciel tu en
penses quoi sinon toi
bonjour soit qui commence bas niveau
photo je pense que ça reste pas mal
quand google a montré ses preuves sur le
vix l2 après bon c'est mon android pur
donc ça c'est cool aussi ouais mais je
me vois pas aller dessus d'accord
maintenant définitivement pas il ya pas
mal de zones d'expérience pour tester
vraiment l'optimisation de la photo les
modes portrait les double caméra à
l'avant de 8 mégapixels dont une avec
invente angle la caméra arrière 12
mégapixels un truc qui est vraiment
hyper lumineux qui fait vraiment des
photos hyper cali en mode portrait qui
est vraiment très très très bien
détaillé jusque dans les moindres
recoins et celle là où on va tout la
force de frappe de google notamment au
niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
donc la photo va rester complètement
hallucinante là dessus on voit une
machine qui fonctionne extrêmement bien
avec instinct dragon 845 une batterie de
2900 milliards eur et annonce 1,9 jours
d'autonomie vraiment chose de
complètement optimisé pourrait se dire
de 1900 milliards d'erreur c'est pas
énorme mais il faut vraiment prendre en
compte là dessus c'est tout le travail
qui est fait derrière non pas du
logiciel au niveau de la toujours
difficile c'est à dire lorsque vous avez
pas besoin à 100% par exemple d'utiliser
votre machine en termes de performance
va y avoir une vraie économie qui va
être fait du point de vue logiciel et ça
c'est vraiment intéressant pour
optimiser complètement votre bécane
[Musique]
m
alors tant pourquoi on a faim enfin rien
à manger ici pourquoi donc cette fois
c'est de la balle centre
la photographie est assez incroyable
malgré des specs qu'ils sont
oh si dingue que ça on nous annonce 12
méga à l'arrière 8 en frontal et
c'est
un jour tu en penses quoi ouais moi je
moi j'adore le côté point de vue
purement design standard
voilà c'est standard par contre d'un
côté optimisation logiciels saas est un
lieu assez dingue et en lait cru qu'on a
pu voir au niveau de la photo sous sa
coupe on peut passer juste noce ment pas
mieux on est comme ça comme à la maison
on est détendu ouais je le trouve assez
cool en termes de photos vidéos mode
portrait il est dingue ventes en dollars
entre la 2 x 8 méga pixels assez et le
prix le prix le prix le prix marie
ndiaye pas mal bata à il est élevé mais
de la côte et il se dit dans les google
on va sortir un pixel 3xl il le faire
500 euros tu vois je disais les chinois
font à noter qu'en quinze minutes de
recharge vous allez pouvoir gagner 7
heures d'autonomie sans smartphone qui
est disponible en précommande et
maintenant d'ailleurs si vous intéresse
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description et que vous pourriez
recevoir à partir du 2 novembre prochain
au tarif 2 859 euros pour le pixel 3 et
959 euros pour le pixel 3xl goûter que
vous avez deux versions une version 64
giga et une version 128 go de stockage
google nous aussi présenté les google
buzz c'est à dire des petits écouteurs
sans fil qui sont disponibles ou tarif
de 179 en rouge et les antisèches deux
côtés qui sont juste là a tout appris
par coeur à partir du 2 novembre
prochain dans deux coloris noir ou blanc
à noter que google afin partenariat avec
douze créateurs différentes vous propose
des coques hallucinante magnifique au
tarif de 39 euros 99 et vous avez aussi
de sur les coques made by google à 45
euros
notez qu'à mexico kla pouvez recharger
votre smartphone en induction et ça
aussi on apprécie c'est vachement bien
justement pour recharger votre
smartphone rapidement vous avez l'eau
pixelsense qui au tarif de 79 euros pour
avoir de la recharge rapide en induction
et puis plein de petites fonctionnalités
qu'on peut avoir par ce qu'ils sont
vraiment intéressantes
c'est intéressant que c'est comme ça un
google phone ouais t'as pas de surcouche
avec un milliard d'applications inutiles
et ses essais assez épuré j'ai posé la
question peut alors se gardant aboutir
j'ai eu la surcouche il me regarde
j'étais plutôt bien mais je disais qu'on
ne s'est pas excusé moi en terme de
design seul le pixel 3 olympique cet
excellent on voit qu'on n'est pas dans
un truc complètement révolutionnaire
propulsé 3 vous allez avoir une petite
barre en haut une petite barre en bas
bon on est dans des standards de ce que
pour trouver notamment chez samsung
parce que sans pixel 3xl vous avez une
petite encoche en haut un enfant en bas
c'est pas complètement dingos par contre
qui ouvre sur ces machines je trouve
c'est vraiment le côté logiciel
d'optimisation software par rapport au
hardware et ce après coup on va vraiment
la force de frappe de google la suisse
est assez impressionnant des spartines
qu'on a
particularité d'avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est conservé
au volant des smartphones qu'on va
tester très prochainement dont je vous
invite à vous abonner
comme ça au moins on pourra en reparler
une fois qu'on leur ment on va tous
testés au niveau logiciel aurait testé
la photo la vidéo enfin on va faire
énormément de choses avec croyez moi ça
va être vraiment vraiment super course
au maintien bien gens qu'on fait rire
est ce que tu veux je dise tu vois qu
est ce que tu en penses toi de ses
pixels était xl droit j'aime bien le
j'aime bien le petit que c'est le croire
le xl un petit peu moins à cause d'une
autre
pour qu'elle prenne en compte ou non et
des trousses de la terre celle du tu
vois du monde sera super banco qui est
vraiment petit
ouais une grosse encoches bien
dégueulasse un peu de gens s'en présente
et vous seriez zida mère je suis
journaliste et un petit peu blogueurs et
c
d'un côté je vais dire c'est sans
surprise et l'autre côté c'est pas sûr
on a des petits produits des petites
améliorations techniques
quand on voit vraiment sur la photo sur
l' usage bien qu'on peut pas comprendre
en pilote
ensuite c'est encore c'est du google
donc ça manque un peu de l'amour donc là
on voit un produit qui valent très cher
très techno donc si quelqu'un est ce que
le grand public va réagir à ce prix là à
ces technologies et tu vois on te vend
plein de téléphone qui sont moins bons
techniquement et on les vend beaucoup
plus cher un sport c'est pour le parfum
nucléaire par exemple apple on peut
aller sur le haut profil dicks aussi
parce que vous prenez pas cette marque
elle dégage quelque chose et un truc
c'est encore à construire en tout cas
quand elle traduit en main peut pas
rester insensible
c'est ce côté cannois de ses troupes du
techno ou c'est un produit que je suis
là et lifestyle que j'estime parfois
presque parfait c'est à dire que le
contenu de l'histoire qu'il raconte
autour est aussi important que le
contenu et la google nous a t-il pour
l'ami l'attique doigts font par contre
il faut pas raconter d'histoires son
panier un contexte
au final c'est qui va s'en servir tandis
qu' un iphone on repère à peu près 15 h
un bon repère une vie un pixel
hélas pas rennes qui est trop le moment
on fait ça donne vraiment performant
c'est vrai que c'est après l'annoncé
après c'est toujours une chose c'est
toujours plus de possibilités pour
consommer pour simplifier la vie ou
consommer toujours plus de services
google
ça me tient très bien en fait pareil de
ce qu'ils aient tous les services type
automne pour nous simplifier la vie et à
côté vous lisez des vrais livres dvd
c'est parce qu il ya un pouce bleus je
crois que ça s'appelle youtube ouais
mais monsieur monsieur grottes
préhistoriques j'aime bien non mais
c'est sympa parce qu'on puisse atteindre
un ca non ça fait un bout de chaîne à
mon boulot aussi
où est assis prendra-t-elle variable et
mon enfant monsieur jouhaud des ruines
antiques aussi mais jamais fait a relevé
que j'ai appelé vous suivra leur sang
coule
[Musique]